ça y est vous nous dites n'en est
apparemment anodine nous dit non à ce
deal vous dit non non c'est pas vrai ce
que vous dites malheureusement c'est
faux c'est faux puisque la réalité
au jour d'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
répondre aux besoins de la population
ce que j'ai dit à mes joueurs qu'on ce
que j'ai dit là monsieur le président
entendez les deux dossiers et ce n'est
pas d'hier mais de dossiers à se débiner
abricotiers sont pas ouais sont liés ils
rejoignent et de dossiers chantier du
dossier je veux dire ce que j'ai dit à
monsieur le président de la république
ce matin il n'est pas normal que
monsieur et madame tout le monde qui
décide de se faire soigner à l'hôpital
public doivent attendre six mois
huit mois un an voire plus pour avoir un
rendez-vous à l'autre à l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui
cyril il ya une réunion organisée par la
direction et le corps médical pour le
personnel nous avons demandé à
l'administration d'organiser cette
réunion et le personnel qui sont venus
nombreux
la question a été dit qu'est ce que vous
allez mettre en place si il ya une
population qui arrive parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les
moyens d'exercer notre profession dans
l'état actuel il a été répondu bah on
baissera l'activité dans d'autres
secteurs
il a été répondu aujourd'hui à la pitié
salpêtrière on baissera l'activité dans
d'autres secteurs mais expliquer ce
qu'ils savent mais ça veut dire que va t
on va fermer
on fermera à services de retour des
déchets nourrir germera a service voilà
que non mais concrètement certes demain
vous allez finir le cavalier leur
plaisait d'une hernie une hernie
inguinale
cette opération n'est pas urgente il est
possible qu'on des programmes des blocs
opératoires à ouvrir des lits
supplémentaires à dire tout ce qui n'est
pas uniquement pour accueillir des
personnes en bus qui a des plans qui
souhaitent accéder aux médecins vous
êtes médecin vous savez ce que ça veut
dire vous savez très bien
perte de chance cette perte de chance
combien de patients malheureusement
décède un manque de réactivité de
rapidité parce qu'on les a pas pris en
temps et en heure pour les sauver ça
veut dire que aujourd'hui par le manque
de moi d'effectifs et de moyens on aura
un taux de perte de chances élevées et
des morts importants ont bien sûr
d'autres après moi je suis pas
je suis pas spécialisé pour les
surprises je suis passé il est important
aujourd'hui on c'est pas du bon sens et
ses deux jours aujourd'hui décrit diable
meurent d'infections nosocomiales à
l'hôpital vous mélangez n'a pas les
moyens au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est une
réalité
et si on injecte au 10 mars des moyens
suffisamment à l'hôpital bah y aura peu
de chance juste beaucoup plus élevé le
professeur fait un spectacle vraiment
pour terminer il faudrait dire que dans
notre pays on est un pays on est riche
on a de l'argent il faudrait injecter
des vrais moyens à l'hôpital public et
de l'argent suffisamment pour pouvoir
fonctionner pas faire de politique mais
sachez qu'elle est d'accord mais c'est
un douzième position ne sera vue ou
cernant la perte de chez et les
pathologies graves
les la riposte des hôpitaux qui a été
écrite cette semaine par tous les
hôpitaux permet de trier tous les
patients graves ou ayant un risque de
perte de chance pour qu'il soit pris
prioritairement dans les hôpitaux
donc le déprogrammer ce sont des choses
non urgents alors pour le métier des
médecins c'est quand même encore de
trier les patients comme chez soi le
thalys ont déposé leur démission
en dix ans de cela n'a rien à voir avec
les finir j'ai pas vu les siens
aujourd'hui nos confrères disent qu'on
ne peut pas travailler dans l'état
actuel et si on n'agit pas il y aura des
conséquences avec ça vous dit de
couronnes un virus justement voulez vous
un instant comment voulez-vous scellier
c'est le même hôpital
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va faire
merlin l'enchanteur échanger tout d'un
coup ce que il dit
et tous les gens qui sont sur le terrain
le disent c'est que si on ne n'accélère
pas des déblocages budgétaire pour
renforcer muscler un peu l'hôpital dans
les deux mois qui viennent pour
anticiper et éventuellement je ne
souhaite pas une crise grave
eh bien on sera coupable parce qu'on
n'aura pas fait le boulot
donc moi je veux dire on a les moyens la
france peut tout à fait affronter cette
épidémie à la condition de ne pas être
dans le train train qui consiste à dire
avant
la réserve sanitaire on mobilise la
réserve sanitaire sa réponse et il ya
des soldes bien mais il ya des choses
bien citoyenne républicaine très
intelligente et très collective mais
voyez que les soignants ou les médecins
dans une période d'épidémie imaginer
leur nez à la télé mais le mandat julien
dray sauver mais ni le raisonnement
demande et demande des moyens
supplémentaires urgents vers la flemme
alors les séries oui ça vous j'ai juste
de vous avez dit le prof m'a chauffé
sera le professeur christopher rap vous
avez dit on a déjà traversé d'autres
crises sanitaires comme le virus h1n1
par exemple où la grippe aviaire
on a appris de tout ce qui s'est passé
oui créer des plans efficaces et les
hôpitaux français sont suffisamment
armée pour gérer pour nous confirmer ça
on a effectivement une colonne
vertébrale des doctrines qui est très
très solide on a une coordination qui
est bonne on fait des exercices chaque
année on a au fil du temps mieux gérer
les épidémies j'ai personnellement gérer
les cailles bola en france et depuis on
a fait des retours d'expérience et on a
réécrit les protocoles
tout est écrit on s'adapte et on
travaille les experts jours et demi en
ce moment pour appuyer pour éclairer la
décision des politiques et donc cette
coordination là il n'y a pas beaucoup de
pays qui l'ont il ya peut-être que les
américains les anglais et les allemands
parce qu'ils ont c'est à dire que vous
l'avez écouté le directeur général de la
santé tout à l'heure s'exprimer c'est
pas un politique c'est aux
fonctionnaires de la santé quelqu'un de
sa carrière active sont rendre hommage
bien été gérée à sauter mais ces
infections mais c'est seulement
quelqu'un de sérieux mon jeu vous
rapporter des propos qu'il a indiqué par
rapport à la question qui nous est posée
il a dit qu'il y avait cent trente-huit
établissant 8 qui était aujourd'hui tu
sens 838 et en 1838 accusé moi d'être un
peu précis donc sur trois qui sont aussi
un trader
dans une conférence de presse de qu'il
ya deux heures qu'ils avaient 138
établissements qu'ils étaient prêts à
accueillir du public
il a dit que ce public là qui seraient
accueillis sur et le public
évidemment le plus vulnérable face à sur
la contamination qui émane du virus que
les autres qui seraient touchés seraient
plutôt une posture de confinement donc à
domicile parce qu'effectivement les
experts que j'ai vu défiler et moi j'ai
envie de donner et de faire confiance
aux experts que le vouliez ou non alors
après on peut raconter tout et n'importe
quoi se faire plaisir
2 que se faire peur même la réalité
c'est que les experts nous indique que
quand on n'a pas de pathologie quand on
est plutôt en bonne santé
le risque est minime c'est à dire que le
risque zéro le risque est minime et que
le confinement à la maison pourrait
suffire mais qu'il faut traiter les
personnes les plus vulnérables
l'assuré est à dire les personnes âgées
c'est à dire les mots nous y sommes est
ce à dire ceux qui sont frappés déjà
d'une pathologie et le directeur général
de la santé monsieur simplement que j'ai
envie de croire qu'après moi de vous le
dire dis qu'il ya 58 établissements qui
sont prêts à accueillir ce public là
voilà pourquoi moi je dis oui parce que
j'ai envie encore une fois de croire ces
gens là qui n'en sommes pas là pour nous
mentir qui n'ont aucun intérêt à mentir
et qui font preuve de plus encore la
crise de transparence ouais enfin soit
rapidement deux choses première chose
concernant la crise hospitalière on la
connaît il ya eu des moyens qui ont été
mis des moyens que vous n'avez pas voté
monsieur du poignant au fait mais que
nous avons mis à part c'était très court
oui voilà deuxième chose qui lui apporte
en cendres des établissements par
département et même les matches un par
département et même plus nous avons
l'habitude en france et il l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure le professeur ap
nous avons l'habitude en france et nous
sommes entraînés avoir des afflux
massifs des afflux massifs ou de blesser
ou de patients moi en tant qu spitalier
le directeur général et la cellule de
crise du chu de montpellier a mon numéro
de téléphone
ils peuvent m'appeler 24h 24 et je vais
sur la cellule exactement comme une
comment dirais-je comme le déploiement
d'une médecine de guerre on sait faire
les les armes et le savent les civils le
savons vous la france est prête
la france est prête à faire front mais
simplement évidemment on est dans une
situation où il ne faudrait pas en
arriver là et que ce matin les choses
ont été bien décrite en face un
face2face trois phases 1 nous sommes
dans la phase 1
c'est à dire quelle est alors la phase 1
ce sont des cas qui à apparaître comme
ça hier il n'avait n'avait 18,7 au
championnat 38 et ses 38 cas tant sur un
essai très important c'est 38 cas
pourquoi nos 38 cas par rapport aux 24
qu'on avait hier soir c'est pas
forcément des nouveaux cas ce sont des
cas qu'on est allé chercher par l'
enquête épidémiologique la chorale en
catimini mesure on a dit tiens ce
monsieur il a contacté il avait en
contact avec la ils étaient en lice
ipte avec deux autres personnes donc on
est allé voir les deux autres personnes
ont été hospitalisées on regarde si
elles sont contaminées ou non
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a augmenté le
nombre de cas la phase 2 est une preuve
de sérieux c'est absolument la phase 2c
le kloster c'est à dire qu'enfin vous
avez des des groupements comme en italie
la vénétie est contaminé c'est une zone
à risques la lombardie c'est une zone à
risque
nous n'en sommes pas là et la phase 3 cd
pilier dacquois donc nous sommes enfin
ça craint et pas en phase 3 je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être vigilant
pour pas passer la phase 2 et surtout
mon papa c'est la face et jean-pierre
exactement mon risque d'épidémie il ya
un risque parce qu'il faut se comporter
et arriverait que nous sommes
je voudrais juste un rabin et la chine
la chine est un sujet très intéressant
parce que la chine
on a contraint autoritairement les
personnes à rester chez elle puis on
rigolait pas quoi les a il sentait pas
bon et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que
la diminution progressive de la
contamination
donc ça veut dire quoi n'est pas
question de faire comme en chine mais on
y arriver mais il est question aux
mignan de limiter au maximum la
contamination interhumaine entre les
entre les jambes des femmes
voilà et ne pas sortir donc aux français
que c'était fini on sait qu'on peut
lutter conte à des moyens qu'on a des
outils de lutter contre ce virus en
soyant est ce qu'on pensait oui c'est la
rumeur voilà qui tourne depuis quelques
temps est ce qu'on pensait que dans une
dizaine de jours voire quinzaine de
jours on sera obligé comme la chine de
rester confinés chez soi je sais pas
mais c'est possible mais c'est possible
bon d'accord il a aussi sur les salariés
de mesures que le gouvernement a pris
les vingt jours possible de que pour
effrayer la raison parce que ces
quatorze effectivement donc le temps de
confinement de ce qui est permis ça veut
dire que s'il ya des alertes et des
signaux pour tout salarié dans notre
pays aujourd'hui il peut rester ou d'un
joueur la maison sans avoir de deux
jours de carence et de jours de mois
qu'en journée une copine qui était hors
sujet homme était une mauvaise note
autant je trouvais que monsieur de leurs
vous étiez hors sujet parce qu'on
voulait avoir des informations sur le
virus et vous avez des informations
politiques autant là vous êtes à 100%
dans le sujet la france qu'elle prête et
là vous êtes dans votre rôle tout à
l'heure aux effets une bande-annonce sur
le virus et voudrait parler d'autre
chose c'est pour ça qu'il ya malentendu
non moi je ne je ne supporte pas qu'on
dise du mal de l'hôpital français même
si on sait qu'il a des problèmes
je dis simplement que dans un état
d'urgence ces problèmes peuvent être
mises de manière subsidiaire
dans un second temps meilleurs
secondaire parce que là il ya une
urgence et il faut avoir bien peu
voyager pour se plaindre de l'hôpital
français qui est un hôpital exceptionnel
je crois même qu'il ya aucun pays au
monde où on arrive à avoir ce niveau de
compétence faut aussi rendre hommage
dans le bon sens c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs plein de gens du monde entier
viennent aussi dans le sud est par
ailleurs et que le personnel hospitalier
est incroyable et on voit cyril que ce
virus accord ce virus un déclenché des
choses phénoménal on assiste quasiment
une démondialisation ce moment il est en
train de bouleverser la notion de
frontière à la notion d'europe on parle
plus d'europe l'italie la france on
raisonne en termes de pays isolé le
virus est en train de modifier le temps
c'est à dire tout d'un coup il ya un
temps qui va extrêmement vite et de
modifier l'espace
l'espace est statique on reste chez soi
donc le temps lui est immobile le
l'espace est immobile et le temps n'a
jamais été aussi rapide donc ce virus
est en train de bouleverser absolument
tout y compris les commentaires qui sont
eux-mêmes viraux